- What up, what up, what
up everyone it's Gary V.
This is pod sessions number nine.
I have three phenomenal guests,
I'm going to allow them
to introduce themselves
in a& minute, who they are
where they're from, what they do
and then we'll go through this show.
We haven't done one of these in a while.
What's fun about this
is maybe unlike any other pod sessions
I've already spent time
with all three individuals
so it makes it a little cozier,
it's a little warmer
I'll try to do my best to
not forget any of the context
or make sure it gets thrown in here
but these are three people
that I have a lot of respect for
for different reasons
and so I'm excited about this show.
So let's start with the lovely lady
to the left of me
and we'll go around,
who are you?
What do you do?
Where are you from?
What's your scene?
- Oh, my name is Lexy Pantera,
and I'm a singer, actress,
entertainer, dancer
and I own my own companies, clothing line,
twerk out class
and yeah, that's me,
I'm from L.A.
L.A. and Sac-town.
- Twerk out class?
- Twerk out!
- So, how, so real quick
before we go further,
you live in L.A. now.
- Yep.
- We're in New York.
- I love New York.
- Real quick, which
city do you like better?
New York or L.A.?
Tell the truth don't bull shit, it's okay.
- I'm going to tell you the truth.
I love living in L.A. 100% because
you have like
- [?] Cause' of the sunshine?
- Everything, I mean
you can get the ocean,
the, I like it better there.
- But we have ocean here.
- Um....
- [Guest] We do.
(laughter)
- We have fucking ocean here.
don't dis my ocean.
- I've actually, I don't think
I've really been to an ocean
anywhere near New York.
- Well, we need to change that.
- But, I like the energy here
so when I come here, I
get a huge amp of energy
and then I go to L.A.
Like running shit so..
- I got it, I understand that.
How often do you get to New York?
- Every couple months I
think, I try to come back.
- I'm glad you're here Lex.
- Oh, me too, thanks for having me.
- We'll dig into it in a little bit.
My man?
- Hey, what's up.
My name is David Ben David.
Founder, creative director
and CEO of Sprayground.
Sprayground is bags, luggage,
its a whole world of chaos
for the creative outcasts of the world.
- I love that, so for
everybody whose listening
I want to just jump in here as well
Sprayground, when I think about brands
that are doing it right,
especially in the apparel or
whatever that genre's called,
not food.
You know like bags or luggage
or sneakers or t-shirts
or things of that nature.
Very few brands I think
have navigated culture,
the attention of the consumer better
than Sprayground over the last decade
so when we got to meet
I really enjoyed that
and I'm excited you're here.
- Thank you bro.
- You got it my man.
- Yo, Nigel Sylvester here,
professional bike rider,
rational dreamer,
- [Gary] I like that.
- I just make shit happen bro,
you feel me?
- I do feel you, but for the
percentage of the audience
that doesn't know who you are
let's go into the,
the professional bike
rider thing is really cool
in my opinion.
- [Nigel] No, of course.
- When you say that, what do you mean?
- So I ride BMX bicycles
on a professional level.
- He can fly.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- Content creator so for
me it's always been about
creating videos and shooting dope photos
and just sharing my story
being a kid from Queens, New York and
going about my sport in a
very unconventional way.
- So, let's break that down.
I'm going to actually piggy back off this.
I'm going to actually go
back the other way around.
I want to go into comic book number one.
The origin story.
Like, cool, I know where
you're from, what you do,
now let's go a hair deeper.
Like, paint the picture for the audience.
This is also I know we're recording it
but there's also audio.
Like where were you born,
how did it happen?
Like what's your story, like parents.
Like, give me some real
fucking like gnarly
001 stuff.
- No, for sure, so I'm a first--
- [Gary] Born in Queens.
- Born in Queens first
generation to immigrant parents
both of my parents from
an island called Grenada
um, where.
- The U.S. invaded in the early 80s.
- (snickers) Yeah but
- On that Reagan shit.
- But even like BMX was
even a thought there
they didn't know anything about that.
- Of course not.
BMX is not a thought in Queens either.
Which is why I'm really excited.
(everyone laughs)
Let's keep it very real.
So, keep going.
- Thankful for X-Games and
ESPN and things of that nature.
- And is that what happened?
You were growing up
here, you're in Queens.
You're watching ESPN
you're seeing people flipping off of
like on the bikes and your
like, yo, that's fresh?
- I was like it's super dope
seeing dudes like Dave Mirra
and Mat Hoffman, Ryan Nyquist
seeing those dudes like ride contests
and kill it and
they're becoming like
these BMX superheroes.
And I was like man, that looks super cool
I wanna do that.
They didn't really have those
facilities out in Queens,
we had to make due with whatever we had so
grinding the ledge and hand rail stair set
whatever we could find.
- I'm really interested in this shit.
So literally you see it,
do you run to your mom and say
can you buy me a bike?
- No, we had to find a bike.
There's certain ways to find bikes.
- Like steal em'?
(laughter)
- I wouldn't say that
but there's certain ways
to find bikes in Queens.
- So you found your first bike.
- I found my first bikes
and um' you know just finding bikes like
throughout my childhood I found bikes
and would try tricks you
know like jump off a curb
with make like a little board ramp.
- And did you have a crew?
You know what's interesting
to me about Queens,
like how long ago, how old are you now?
- I'm 31.
- And this is when you were how old?
- I was a kid man, six,
seven years like it started.
You know?
- So, 25 years ago,
I grew up in this area.
Like being in Queens and
rolling up on your homies
and being like yo, let's BMX versus
video games or basketball
or all of the other things.
Like did you have a crew,
were people into it or
was it just like one or two of you?
- See the thing about it though is like,
growing up in Queens
everyone would ride bikes
so whether you go from
the house to the park
to go play basketball
or from your crib to your friend's house
to go play video games it
was a mode of transportation
and then having a dope bike was important.
So having like GT with the mags
or a Dino with the mags on it
that was something that was important.
- It starts early, capitalism baby.
- Course, you know what I mean
you gotta have a fresh bike.
- Those Joneses those fucking Joneses.
Keep going.
- So that would like easily translate
from like, ok you have a dope bike,
now can you pop a wheelie?
Oh how long can you pop a wheelie for?
Oh can you jump off this curb and for me,
- [Gary] It just built.
- It just kept building and building.
I became addicted to the
feeling of landing tricks.
I want land bigger tricks.
I want to go and grind longer
or pop a wheelie longer
and I just took that and
just kept running with it
and as I would ride
through the neighborhood
I would meet different kids
who rode bikes and what not
and like...
- And the best players could
figure each other out right?
- [Nigel] Of course so,
- So then you've got the A crew.
- Not really, it was more just like
this is like the Alpha in the crew.
- Don't feel bad because if
all the kids are riding bikes
and everybody's got their little crew
the best rider in each crew
eventually there's a point
where those wanted to come together
no different than basketball,
by the way, entrepreneurship.
The other kids that knew
how to sell baseball cards
became my homies.
- [Nigel] You guys
would share information.
- It's all the same shit.
Video games.
How many times do you want
to beat your boy in Madden?
88 - nothing, you gotta find
somebody else that can play.
- Yeah of course and
then you would share that
information and once I
started find out about places
like Union Square.
I was like, okay I gotta leave Queens
and go to the city because
that's where the best riders are
so like you were saying,
- That's the major leagues.
- Everyone would go out to
this spot and we'd all meet up.
- [Lexy] That's cool.
- Because if you sucked
at riding bikes like me
you would just stay in Queens.
You're not going there to get clowned on.
- No, like I'm riding in front of my crib
to Jamaica station and
then jump on the E train
all the way to 14th and then
ride across to Union Square.
- Love it, love it.
- It was a whole journey
everyday to get to the city
to hang out with the
best riders in the city.
- When did you realize that
you were really really good?
Right away?
That happens right?
- [Nigel] Nah.
- No, no, no, I mean this
this is not a,
you don't need to be bashful like
now you go to the major leagues.
You're in Union Square,
that's when all these steps in life
you sometimes realize like,
oh okay I'm not going to be in the NBA
oh okay I'm not going
to be an E sport star,
or oh okay I'm not going
to be an entrepreneur
that makes 10 billion dollars
there's a moment or the reverse,
which is like, wait a minute
if that dude's the best, I'm like that.
That's a very important moment
for everybody in their life.
I'm just curious, you're very special
at that craft of riding.
I'm curious like when did you say
oh shit, I'm real good.
- When, I feel like that
happened at two different points.
The first point was when I
realized I need to get out
of my neighborhood because like the,
I feel for, when you put
yourself around other people
that are super good, super
amazing at what they do
it helps you raise your bar.
- [Gary] Always.
- So I felt like I needed to
be around way better riders
to help me raise my bar.
So it happened then.
And then once I got on that scene
and I started to see the
tricks that I was doing
I was like okay, cool,
like now I understand
I'm in a good position
and if I continue to grind
super hard and be true to myself,
which is a very very
important thing as well,
being true to yourself,
that's when I realized that cool,
like something that's really here
that I can really bubble off of.
- I love it, I got some more
stuff for you in a minute.
- [Nigel] Of Course.
- [?] Praise the Lord.
- Let's keep it going.
How bout you?
Born where?
- No, I love it, this guy's special.
Everywhere I go in the world
I always bump into him.
- Is that true?
- [David] Yeah, I saw him last-
- Well it makes sense, it makes sense.
Knowing you two.
- In Dubai, just randomly.
I have a partner he owns
a house and a zoo there
and I was there and he just...
- Like a giraffe and zebra zoo?
- Yeah, he has like a thousand animals.
- Every animal.
- Tigres, lions.
- Ligres.
- So you wanted to go there for content.
- Ligres?
Cause, I want to see that.
- There's two ligres and
there's only six ligres.
- I don't even know what a ligre is.
Oh, that's a half lion, half tiger?
- Is this a real thing?
- Yeah, its a real thing.
It's really serious,
it's very scary looking.
- Oh I thought it was made up.
- Soon there's going
to be like lion human,
shit the science...
- [Lady] Human lions?
- Oh we're about to
become so crazy out here.
Like you think fake lips
and fake asses are crazy?
Like we're going to be
half lion, half human soon.
- Oh, I can't wait.
- Science is coming guys
don't sleep on science.
The robots are coming.
By the way, on a serious
note, cloning is close.
- [Lady] Oh shit...
- Like just to get it real
weird in here real quick
and by the way I'm interested.
- Well, what's the point?
- I want to live forever.
- [Nigel] Productivity
will go all the way up.
- The point is like, I'm
going to make another me
and be like, if I get hit by a tree
other me is going to
be fucking dominating.
- [Nigel] A tree?
- But your conscious and
your soul and your heart...
- But your not there.
Unless they can download your brain.
- [Lady] Exactly.
- I don't know it's so fucking crazy.
Honestly, it's like internet.
I'm old enough, there's
some youngsters in here.
You actually don't know life pre-internet.
Let me tell you something,
you didn't know the internet
was going to be a thing.
Like, you didn't know how
insane it was going to be.
You didn't know how it
was going to change at,
I don't know you're probably right
but I don't know idea
what a cloned me and a me
interact what's that going to be like,
I just think it's going to be amazing.
- Hopefully, I hope so.
- The fact that I can be here
and give a keynote right
now in Dubai, oh shit.
- [David] I just hope it's not expensive.
- [Nigel] Facts, productivity
is going to go all the way up.
- [Lexy] Save your money now.
- Tyler your job is in jeorpardy my man.
(laughter)
Origin story, origin story, let's do it.
Born where?
- I was born in the Bronx.
My family, my parents split up early.
- Was that like a tough big event.
- No, looking back it was awesome
because I don't want to be like that guy,
even though he's a nice guy in theory
but like I don't want to be like that
and that's what keeps me going
so that's what makes me hungry
for blood.
- Mhmm, I understand that.
So that happened early.
- So then moved to Florida
and I guess I just got
stuck in stuck in like,
- What part of Florida?
- Hollywood, Florida, a nice
little neighborhood there.
And I was always put in front of a TV.
I watched movies since I was young.
And looking back also,
that's probably a good thing.
Because it helped fuel my creativity.
Not that I'm saying you should
put your kids in front of T.V. and movies
but I saw movies and for some reason it--
- This is interesting you said this.
This gives me a chance to get off
something I'm passionate about
all the current parents in the world
shit on Ipads and Iphones
limit your kids this that.
I'm completely the other way.
- Really?
- Yeah Lex, I'm like what world?
- I don't know I was super
creative when I was young
and like imaginative,
you know what I mean?
- Me too and what have you
but here's what I'm saying
what world do you think our
kids are going to be living in?
Like technology doesn't go backwards.
Like everybody demonizes shit
without realizing all the benefits.
Like, it's just so interesting.
- [Nigel] You're right
you got a good point.
- Like, think about this.
I just asked you about your origin story
within the first two minutes
you talk about consuming content
in video form from a device.
Like, I you know, I just think
that people underestimate
shit, so anyway keep going.
- Yeah, did that.
Went to a little private
school of about 26 kids
and I always used to draw on the board,
like crazy images
and then the teacher would
come and he would make sure
that I would erase the board.
It was a little pornographic,
I mean I was young.
You know like 12 years old
drawing these crazy scenes on the board
and all the kids were loving it
and they wanted me to do
it before class started.
- And did you love the attention?
- [Lady] That's cool.
- Huh?
- Did you love the attention?
- Yeah, that my art was getting
like people getting going.
It was awesome, that I could do that.
But, it got me suspended twice.
Which was okay (laughs)
- That's fine, it was
good for the origin story.
- Yeah, and I didn't really
want to pursue something
in creativity, I wanted
to pursue something
for a minute of my time, I
wanted to go to the military.
I don't know why.
I liked how the military
designed their things.
Like, a bullet, you know it's
designed through science.
It has to be aerodynamic.
An F16 Fighter Jet, like that thing,
it just excites me.
You know I like action movies.
Maybe that's why, see
where this is all going?
So my mom pushed me to go to arts school.
So I went to the School
of Visual Arts here
and after I graduated I
pursued a career of creativity.
And it's been uh-
- What happened first?
- In regards to?
- Your career, what was
the first thing you did?
- Oh, I just jumped in and
started doing my own thing.
I didn't want to work for anybody.
- Really, right off the gate.
So what did you make first.
- Because they wouldn't understand me.
I actually applied to
100 jobs no one took me
and I just started with just my own thing
got some financing.
- Which was what?
- With the bags.
- Right to the bags?
- Pretty much.
- No shit, I didn't know that.
- I didn't know how to make a bag.
I had to go to China a few times
to figure that out.
- How long ago was this?
- I started it eight years
ago but probably about a year
and change of just figuring shit out.
- So almost like 9 or 10 years ago.
- But our real official,
2020 will be our 10 year anniversary.
So that's exciting.
- We'll get into that a little bit.
- Lex?
- Hi!
(clears throat)
Let's see, I grew up
in Sacramento and L.A.
Split up home, wanted
to be a singer my entire
existence of life and a dancer.
Everything came natural kind of.
I moved to L.A. when I was sixteen,
had to get out of the hood
cause' my dad was like mhmm
you can't do anything here.
So I went to L.A. got
into acting and stuff.
My whole family does it
so my whole family's into car racing,
what is it called, my dad did stunt work
and all that stuff
but I was never heavily into the business
like I probably the past two years
I've actually learned the
most about the music industry.
- Sure, you just wanted to make music.
- So that's pretty much that.
Yeah, so I've always recorded.
I was in a girl group when I was younger.
- Yeah, let's talk
about that for a minute.
- I was like 17, it was called LXL.
Someone found me at
Millennium Dance Studio
and they were like, hey can you sing?
And I was like yeah, actually I can.
Started recording...
- And so you literally
were like literally,
like some Nsync shit.
- I mean I wish (laughter),
I mean on a lower scale.
Yeah it was like five pretty
cool girls and we all sang.
Like I opened up for Keith
Sweat back in the day.
- That's amazing.
- It was a lot, like
I've been through a lot.
- Like do you guys go to like
malls and perform and shit?
- No we didn't get that far
because the group split up.
I Beyonced out of there.
No, I'm just kidding.
But I left but I've always,
then I went solo started doing an album.
I got some stuff on
Entourage, on the radio,
my dad supported my
whole career pretty much.
- [Gary] Wow, that's amazing.
- He helped me, 100% like
the biggest fan I have.
After that I went on my own more
and started learning
more about the business
and started doing a couple
movies and stuff here and there
but then twerk out class started
and it popped off my whole career.
- [David] What's that?
- This was about five years,
almost five years ago,
it's almost an anniversary for us too.
Twerk out freestyle videos
on Insta' on Youtube.
- [Gary] Vine?
- [Lexy] Online, just boom!
- How much was it Vine oriented?
- Oh no Vine, no no no it was
strictly Facebook, Youtube
and then I went to Instagram.
So I started doing my classes.
First came the classes then
came the Youtube videos.
They went viral.
Then I was like okay,
it was making me money.
I was like cool.
So I got really addicted to it.
I'm like y'all this is making
a bunch of money, whatever
but I wasn't really focusing on my music.
- And you made money
because people would see
the twerk out class and
sign up for the class
or brands were coming to you
and wanted to give you money
to do Instagram photos, like what?
- No, only, only fans.
Only people coming into take the class.
- Understood, so the,
- Yeah, and I had some
celebrity friends at the time
that came in and took so they loved it
so automatically they were
cool posting about it.
- [Gary] Course.
- And that was how it grew.
And then I kept up with the
YouTube and then I was like,
wait, my passion's music so
why am I not focusing on that?
- When did that happen?
- I want to say three years ago.
I've always done it though,
but not fully focused.
- Understood, five years
ago the twerk thing blows up
the studio, the classes
and things of that nature.
Two years into it, even though
you're making a ton of money
you were like, oh fuck, wait a minute
this thing is taking me
away from my true passion
let me refocus, or like
really really focus on music?
- Yeah, yeah, the past year and half
has been really really just music.
Music, music, music.
I started doing like rapping shit
for twerk out videos
because I knew I could
monetize my songs and stuff.
So I was like okay, let's
just make this for that.
But that wasn't the type
of music I wanted to do
so I kind of did that but
then I moved along I'm like
listen I need to just
focus strictly on music,
this is my shit.
- And that's where you're at now.
- That's where I'm at.
- Alright, let's go back
around starting with you Lex.
This is the part where I
want to know what you are
currently obsessed with?
- [Lexy] Right now?
- Yeah, and before you answer this,
I don't mean like some generic ideology.
I mean you bought a new toothbrush
that's so fresh
or you found some show on Netflix
that you can't stop watching
or some sort of product
something very intriguing
in your actual life
where like no cameras on.
What in your life are you
currently obsessed with?
Like a new person, a new gadget,
a new app, a new song, a
new food, a new restaurant?
- Yeah, its a song, definitely a song.
So like, 24/7 so Tripping
on you by Ella Mai.
She sang the Boo song,
literally every single day
I've been listening to that song hard
24/7 so I think that's what it'll.
It's always music, I
think, addicted to music.
- Love it.
- It's my own craft.
Coming up with something new.
Like now I'm making music, cause
right now I could only get-
- [Gary] You're making music?
- [Lexy] Haay!
- Yeah, I could only get the fan
through touch and see now
I want to add another sense
to it, so now music.
- So are you producing or are you singing?
- Yeah, I'm actually making it.
I write it, I sing it.
- Oh snap!
- You sing it?
- Yeah a little bit of.
- That's fucking amazing.
- [David] Yeah it's fun
- [Nigel] Gotta a collabo right here.
(laughter)
- We should get on there too.
Maybe we should start a
band right here, fuck it.
- [Nigel] We should get on
the track and do some adlibs,
what's good?
- Adlibs you got adlibs?
- [Nigel] I got adlibs all day.
- I will market it,
guys no matter how bad our music is
I will market the shit out of it.
We will be number one everywhere.
- Damn, we'll fucking have
a hit single on Billboard.
- This is a wrap, we're going
to be humungous in Hungary.
- But I don't like much things out of...
- You keep shit narrow.
- Like what you said
about other consumer stuff
it doesn't really excite me.
I like airplanes though.
I like reading about Boeing and Airbus.
I like that whole flying thing.
It's just fascinating for my creativity.
- [Lexy] Scary.
- You love engineering huh?
- Yeah, it's awesome.
- That's cool.
- [Gary] Nige?
- I'm going to go with two things.
So, Pedestrians by
Gunner, the song - fire.
- [Gary] He's my guy.
- And then I can't stop
thinking about Ozark.
It's so good.
- People's are obsessed with that show.
Caleb you love it?
- That show is amazing,
it's amazing right?
- [Lexy] Never heard of it.
- Hands down.
- Oh, it's such a big, netflix right?
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- Oh, it's a Netflix show.
- You don't have Netflix?
- I do, I don't watch
a lot of T.V. though.
- You're always in the studio?
- Yeah, I'm always out doing something.
- No trust me, I barely watch T.V. too
but I was hooked on--
- Don't defend yourself Nigel, fuck that.
Fuck what Lexy's saying,
watch your fucking Netflix.
- [Lexy] Like Mirrors, Mirrors is cool.
- I'm just saying how good Ozark is
because I don't watch T.V.
but I binged that thing
like two days that's how serious it was.
- [Lexy] That's funny.
- Guys, I'm in such a coma right now.
I usually don't jump in here,
but I just want everybody
to know on the record
the Jets destroying the
fuck out of the Lions
on Monday Night.
- [Nigel] Amazing.
- Has me on full tilt, I've
barely been productive.
I can't stop thinking about Sunday.
I want to destroy the Dolphins.
Sam Darnold's my guy, Jamal Adams.
Like, I'm such in a coma right now,
I'm literally in a bubble
of New York Jetsome
I'm barely concentrating
- Well these things don't help.
- I got all sorts of shit going-
like I'm barely listening to you guys.
Like, I'm just like, I'm
already thinking about like,
if we can stop the run
and fuck Ryan Tannehill.
- [Nigel] Yeah.
- I'm literally living
like a parallel life
while I'm living my regular life
because I love them so much
and the optimism behind
our new quarterback, huge.
- Hmmm, I have a collab with the NFL,
we should work on the Jets bag.
- [Gary] Let's go!
You should design it.
- Done.
- [Lexy] Oh wow!
- And I suck at designing but
it will be your number one
selling fucking Sprayground of all time.
It's going to look like
shit and fucking dominate.
Sales for days.
- [Lexy] Wow.
- What's going on with
you and social media.
- I love social media bro.
- Good, talk to me about,
talk to me about it as a human
what you fuck with and
then how you think about
for your business or
ambitions or aspirations.
- I mean as a human on some real shit,
sometimes I catch myself like
I'm spending way too much time.
- [Gary] In what?
- In just like scrolling
through Instragram.
- Period.
- Yeah, just looking at shit.
- How much do you live in D.M.?
- All day, all day
like I'm talking to some
of my friends on like a-
- I live in D.M. for sure.
All my friends I'm talking to them 24/7.
It's a form of
communication, text message.
- It is, it is, I'm talking
to people on D.M. all day.
- Fans, real life, relationships, like
talk to me about the graft?
- I'm talking to friends,
I'm talking to fans.
I love to connect with the people
so I'll just go through the,
I guess like the second level of D.M.s
I'll go through some of...
- Yeah, the ones that aren't your friends.
You'll just go in there and say what's up.
- Yeah, I'll say what's up.
I'll talk to people.
- And they go crazy.
- They love it.
They're like, I can't believe
I'm talking to you right now.
- [Lexy] Then they don't
leave you alone though.
- And it's awesome.
- You've got different
dynamics than boys do,
I don't even want,
like honestly all my girl friends,
like I'm just like, sorry
sorry that Instagram D.M. was created
cause' that's a whole different dynamic.
- Yeah, it's crazy, I love it.
- Good for you.
- And then on business, it's
helped me propel my career
to where it is now, it's clutch.
- By the way if you're listening now,
if you have not seen some of
Nigel's videos on YouTube.
They are so incredible,
like, D-Rock was giddy
when we got connected,
do you even understand?
I was like, no I don't
consume anything but the Jets.
He was like, you gotta watch this
I was like wow.
And then when you showed me the preview,
I actually sat and watched that.
- Amazing, yeah I showed
it to you right here.
- Dude, you're such a talent man.
It's very, very impressive.
- [Nigel] Thank you.
It's really cool.
It's super fresh.
- Yeah, I truly enjoy the process
of thinking about certain scenes
and then bringing them to life.
Like that process is incredible.
I feel fulfilled off it now.
- So what do you use,
do you use instagram?
- Instagram, Twitter, Facebook, YouTube.
- Got it, no Snap?
- I don't use Snap.
- What do you do with Facebook?
- Facebook is just like
repost everything I'm doing.
- Did you use Snap 24, 36, 48 months ago?
- No
- Got it.
What about you social?
- Social Facebook more for
the international fans,
so we have international distribution.
- Yep, and this is now
under the Sprayground brand
not you as a person.
- Yeah.
- Understood.
- Sometimes I put too much
attention on the Sprayground
but I mean that's like
the bread and butter
so my own Instagram gets a
little neglected but that's fine
- Yep, have you thought about,
wait a minute, if I'm going to start doing
other creative things like
music and other things,
I may want to think about that.
Has that crossed your mind?
- Yeah, I just need than man power on it.
- I get it.
- But it's good to talk to the fans
and then when I started to do pop ups
in undisclosed locations so
its cool seeing them after
and like oh man, thanks so
much for answering my D.M.
They'll even like snap that and post it,
like we liked that photo.
- That's the post, of course.
- Or like responded back to that.
- Could you imagine when you were a kid
whoever your hero was replying back,
Like when I think about
- [Lexy] Yeah, that's wild.
- Like when I think about Al Toon
my favorite Jet's player,
if in 1988, I D.M.ed
Al Toon and he said Yo
I would have been in a coma for a year,
let a lone a day.
Like, you know I get it,
it makes a ton of sense.
So, for you personally as a
human, do you use anything?
- Yeah, I use Instagram
for, yeah just for me.
- Anything else?
- No, just Instagram.
- No Twitter?
- No, no
- Do you consume anything on YouTube?
- Yeah, just some-
- Like do you go watch plane videos,
how they make planes and shit?
Seriously, I mean it.
- How do they make the Airbus 777.
- That's what's amazing about YouTube
- Yeah, you can see stuff like that.
And just music videos.
- Anybody listening right now,
literally type in anything, it's there.
- [Lexy] That's crazy.
- Like eating hornets, yep it's there.
Lexy, how about you?
- I'm on everything pretty much.
- As a human what do you
use the most, Instagram?
- Instagram.
- Anything else?
- On my phone, probably Twitter.
- I mean my YouTube and
Facebook are really big, but...
- But that's more business-ey?
- Yeah, I haven't been able
to really work my Facebook
as much as I want to.
- What about Snap, do you ever?
- I Snap a little bit.
- Did you used to Snap way more?
- Yeah, I used to Snap way more.
- Yeah, and then Instagram came in there.
- Recently, I've kinda been
not in the camera face to face
as much, I've noticed?
- You've gone the other way?
You're like socially commentating?
- Maybe.
Yeah, I noticed that change recently.
I just told her about it.
- I actually, it's funny you said that.
I literally had a pretty
famous comedian in here
just before we did this.
And I was telling him one of
the things I think he could do
that's really cool is
I think people should take it.
Everybody's to their face right.
It's all us.
I think the way you see the
world is like a big white space.
I think like an Instagram account
could get really fresh if every post was
you talking over what you're looking at.
- That makes sense.
- I think so.
- Like it gives you more of
you, a personality right?
- Yeah, or my big thing is
I think people are getting
way to precious with their posts.
Like the Likes and feedbacks
have crippled people
and everyone's looking for the
perfect shot, the right angle
everyone's gotten real fancy
and I think one of the ways to break fancy
is to go the other way.
Because you're pointing at a stop sign
and you might tell a story
about when you drove past
a stop sign and fucking
got into a car accident.
Like, whatever it may be,
I think that the world
is a canvas of creativity
that people can be using
but they're so focused on themselves
that they're missing
out on all the context.
- [Lexy] I can agree with that.
- That makes sense.
Question for you like what
platforms are you using
on like a human, person to person-
- On a human level, nothing.
- Okay, why not?
- [Lexy] Yeah, lucky you.
- Because I live in text.
As a human, I like, like on my Jets-
I'm a very one-dimensional human
meaning I literally care about
my friends and family, right?
And, the New York Jets.
(laughter)
Like I don't what else
to really to tell you.
And then like.
- Have you met them are you like?
- Yeah, I'm so wired in
I'm going to buy the New York Jets,
just straight up
you're going to sing the national anthem
but you're gonna.
- Wow, pinky promise that!
- Yes, I will right now
but you're gonna be old as fuck.
- Noooooo.
- Yes, you're gonna be
legendary at that point.
- [David] No, she's going to be cloned.
- I need thirty years.
- That's fine, absolutely.
- Yeah, so you keep doing you.
- I will be so happy to do this for you.
- Don't fuck up your voice
and it's done, it's documented.
- [David] And then he's
the half-time show.
- You're gonna be,
but honestly it's really interesting.
Here's what's different about me
definitely than you and
most of the listeners
and a lot of people in the room.
I was an adult when social came.
So, like I have so much
pride in the book I wrote
Crush It.
Like if you read that now,
like what I wrote about
social media in 2008
I was right, so from day one,
in my thirties as a wine store owner.
I used social for business,
I wasn't a human on social.
I wasn't a kid that grew up with social.
Like it didn't exist.
AOL instant messenger didn't exist for me.
I was already grown.
So, for me, social, the internet,
it's always been business,
it's always been business.
Like and so for me
I popped very early and very quick
on Twitter and YouTube in 2006,
so it's been now 12 full years
of me navigating from
a business stand point.
So, I've never been removed
from the business part of social
the way I was never removed from wine.
Like when I drink wine today,
for the first time, in my entire life,
I drink wine today
and kind of enjoy it as
wine, not as business.
Because I grew up in the business of it.
- [Lexy] That's crazy.
- For example, for you
like when you listen to music.
You're actually analyzing
things that I don't.
I just listen to fucking music, right?
- Movies too, it's so upsetting.
- When you see products,
my intuition based on
the way you're talking
you're looking at things from
a different lens than I am.
I'm like that's a sneaker.
- Yeah you don't enjoy it anymore.
- [Lexy] Yeah, you don't enjoy it.
- I just rip it apart,
I'm like that could have been better.
- [Lexy] Oh, I rip it apart (laughter).
- So, that's right,
from a design standpoint
from an engineering stand point
so for me, I don't use social as normal
now as a business person,
I'm like on full tilt
I'm everything, podcast,
linkedin, YouTube,
Medium, Quora, Facebook
we are full pledged media
fucking empire so I'm thinking
about written word, audio,
video, it's, you know it's my life.
So, and not only my life, it's my business
so it's pretty deep in that way.
- Makes sense, but do you enjoy it still?
- Oh I, there's nothing more
exciting than the process
I don't like the stuff
that the process gives you
my great advantage is
I don't like the stuff
that the process gives you.
So, that's my absolute advantage.
Like, I don't want the cars or the houses
I just want to be good at my craft.
- [Lexy] It feels good.
- You know, I love that.
I think I connect with you quite a bit.
I took that away from when
we met like six months ago
or what have you.
I was like, oh fuck.
I understand him, he wants
to be great at his craft.
And, I think everybody does,
but there's some people that actually
only want to be great at their craft.
For me, I only want to
be great at my craft.
Which means I'm always in
the process of my craft.
Which means I get to play forever.
Which means I'm fulfilled.
- I have a question.
What do you think about,
because growing up I
loved to do so many things
and I don't like to do just one.
And I think that's why
why I guess I've been doing
a lot of shit my whole life, right?
- [Gary] Acting and...
- Acting yeah, but how do
you, like do you think that
- I think it's a strength.
I think people shit on it
and say you have to focus.
- A lot of people do.
- Of course they do,
people that aren't artists.
- Well, yeah people that aren't talented.
They can only do one thing.
- Forget about talented.
It's not that.
It's people, it's not that.
It's people, my big thing is
people always come up to me like
Gary Vee, like literally
on the fucking street
because of the way it all went down
Yo, Gary Vee, real quick,
you said in a video last week on Instagram
blah blah blah,
but my homie Jerome said no.
And, I'm like well what's
your homie Jerome up to?
Not much.
I'm like, well think about
whose giving the fucking advice.
- That's very true.
Okay, I like that.
- That's my answer to
you, if a straight man-
- Cause' a lot of people say,
oh you should be focusing on this
- Of course.
- I'm like whoa, I like doing a lot.
- And if you look at them and
they're a lawyer or a manager
that makes sense.
Like, I can't be that.
I have 800 thousand
fucking things going on.
You know why, I will suffocate if I don't.
My core thing Vaynermedia
would not be successful
if I didn't have Gary Vee.
If I didn't have you know Green Street.
If I didn't Vaynersports,
If I didn't have Wine Library.
If I didn't have the K-Swiss collaboration
like if I don't have a fucking
million things going on,
if I focus on one thing,
that fucking thing is dead.
I've been a 200 million
dollar company from scratch
because I've been doing
all this other side hustle.
- Exactly, I like that.
- That's the answer.
- I like that.
- Other people that are artistic,
whether they're business artistic
or as artistic as...
Right, they understand,
everybody here understood that
They've gotta get their
nut off in different ways
but somebody whose not creative
- Amen
- Right, you know?
- [Nigel] That's very true
- The reason you need
to scratch other itches
otherwise you get suffocated.
- Well, what's the point of life right?
- No, but you should at
least master something.
I meet a lot of people
that I want to be a freaking mogul.
Okay, well where you
going to start at first.
I want to do everything.
They want to do
everything, it's a problem.
- To your point,
you just said two things.
Like if you were pitching it that way,
that's exactly right because
they haven't said anything yet.
I want to be a mogul, I
want to do everything.
No, no you didn't say anything yet.
- [David] No, but I hear
that a lot it's a problem.
- Brother, everybody's fucking.
- That's just cause' they
probably want to make money
like I just want to do everything
but we're talking about creative people.
- [David] They're just lost,
they're young and they're lost.
- Like I love acting, I love
singing, I love doing this.
- Yeah, but you know what's so funny.
So many people want to do creative things
because they think that's how
they're going to make money
to your point.
- People do things for the wrong reasons
- [Gary] Correct.
like I agree, you should do something,
I mean, if your fortunate
enough to do something
that you fucking love.
Do it great, do it everyday
as much as you possibly can.
- You're very interesting to me
because you don't look the
part of the normal BMX biker-
and I think that means
you fucking loved it.
Like, I'm really leaning into
a new version of myself on this
like right now, I can't
stop making content around
going to garage sales and
thrift stores and flipping shit,
- [Lexy] I used to do
that when I was younger.
I loved it.
- [Nigel] That's amazing.
I can't stop.
And I have a lot of people saying,
yo, you're hurting your brand,
why are you going into that
who gives a fuck if you
bought something for a dollar
and sold it for eight.
Oh, Gary Vee,
And I'm like I don't give a fuck.
- If it makes you happy right?
- That's a good flip a dollar to eight.
That's a good flip bro.
- [Gary] Fuck!
- [Nigel] Sounds like good money to me.
And, in a world, on a very serious note,
in a world where 98% of
the people listening here
would love to make an
extra 10,000 dollars a year
I know how easy it is if they just listen.
Everybody's trying to
build the next Instagram
meanwhile I just tweeted this.
Some kid, literally as you
guys were walking in here,
some kid's like you Gary
Vee you changed my life
I literally just bought
this Razor scooter at Target
on close out for 70
bucks, I took a picture
of it, this guy took it gangster.
I took a picture of it in the store,
posted it on Facebook marketplace
somebody bought it for $200,
I bought it for $70, drove two miles
and sold it for 200.
- Oh my gosh!
- [Nigel] That's a whole thing in itself.
- I want to do this too.
- That's a mogul in the making.
- And so, by the way
to your point, I love you for that.
To me, when kids are like
Yo, I'm going to build the next Instagram.
Yo, I'm going to build the next Snapchat.
The next Uber.
I'm going to be a mogul.
I'm a this, I'm like, have
you ever made any money?
Like, right?
To me, the lemonade kid, the blow pop kid,
the burner C.D. kid,
the baseball card kid,
when I wake up at 4:30
and go to the airport
cause' I take a lot of 6am flights
and I drive by and see
a bunch of kids in line
knowing they're buying
some limited edition bag,
some limited edition sneaker
some limited edition something.
I look at them and I'm
like those are my people.
Not when I go into these big corporations
and see the CMOs that I love,
I love them but they're not my people.
That doesn't mean they're not good.
That means that they were great at school
they're great at process
that they're great at-
that's just not me.
I'm great at waking up at 3:30,
not giving a fuck what anybody thinks.
Standing in line during
a fucking snow storm
getting my $80 pair of something,
and selling it for fucking
$215 on StockX the next day.
That's me.
- [Nigel] That's good money.
- And I'm going to do that
all the way to winning
six Super bowls in everybody's mouth.
- And me singing the national anthem.
- That's what I'm going to do.
Alright, what are you going to do?
That's what I'm going to do.
Lex, what are you going to do?
- I said I'm going to sing
the national anthem at it,
that's what I said.
- But no, seriously though, please.
- No we were talking about it earlier,
when we first met about how like
I was selling Pokemon cards,
Lemonade stand.
- You should've kept those Pokemon cards.
They're fucking lit now.
- My principal took them.
He was like you're not
allowed to sell those.
- I love that, I remember that.
- I never got them back.
- And, honestly to me
that was such an important part of like
okay, I fuck with her.
That's like my people.
- Isn't that crazy, I was like
now whose gonna pay for my lunch?
Yeah I loved that, I loved
it, that's entrepreneur.
- Let's go around.
What are you most excited about
or trying to achieve
in the next 24 months?
Go Nigel.
- Wow, building my, building the GO brand.
That's what I'm most excited about.
I feel it has great potential, um-
- Tell everybody what the GO brand is.
- So pretty much I do a
video series called GO.
It started off a couple, a few years ago,
just as an idea.
I didn't wait for someone
to tell me yes or no,
I just went out and did it.
Made it, put it on
YouTube and it went viral.
Which was incredible,
and start to bill em'-
- How many are there now five?
- We have five episodes now.
We're well over 50 million views total.
- And how often do you do an episode?
- We do two episodes a year.
- Understood.
- And it's a great platform
because I've been able to-
- Caleb, have you seen em'?
You're gonna shit, I can't
wait for you to see em'.
- You've gotta check it out it's crazy.
But, I'm able to bring my entire world,
like every piece of it.
- [Gary] Oh it's super fresh.
- From like me riding my bicycle,
to travel to style and fashion,
to the people I interact with
all in this one video series.
- So you want to keep building it.
- I want to continue to build that
and also like build up the-
- And what's the aspiration?
Obviously brands want to get integrated,
there's money there.
- [Nigel] Of course.
- You could literally,
I don't know maybe you
could open theaters.
Have you thought about
the business around it
or are you still trying to beat that?
- No of course, beyond just
like the video series itself
there's a whole merch
program that I'm building out
so like bringing in the idea that like,
okay, if I'm in Tokyo and
I get inspired by a design
how can I now go in and recreate that.
Or, give my rendition of what that is.
And also doing live events.
Where like I'm planning
to do a GO festival soon.
- Good for you.
- And bringing the videos to life.
- [Lexy] Ooh, that's cool.
- You know, some entire lifestyle around
or based off of, inspired
by this video series
that I started.
- I love it, me and my guy.
- So building that out
is the most important
thing for me right now.
- [Gary] My man.
- I can't wait to watch that.
- It's crazy, you gotta check it out.
- Yeah, you're gonna really appreciate it.
- That's why I was shooting in Dubai.
You didn't see it, you gotta watch it.
- Yeah, he had the bag on.
- Yeah, the bag on exactly.
- [Gary] What about you 24 months?
- 24 months, I'd like to travel
I'd like to travel for business
I'd like to travel when
there's multiple things to do.
Like fly into Italy, meet a distributor,
do a photoshoot, go to the museum,
meet someone to collaborate
with, do all that.
I like doing that so like do more of it
in undisclosed locations.
Like India, that's my next
thing or like Australia.
I haven't broke that market yet,
that's a focus for us.
I'm doing more runway.
So, I'm expanding in the brand there.
- I like that, and that's a good idea.
- And we have a lot of
interesting collaborations
there with that.
And then the music, the music is fun.
It's called Money on the Plane.
- [Lexy] Oooh.
See, I told you I liked planes.
- There we go.
- Yeah so that's going to be fun.
Cause' to make these visuals.
- Is it like Snakes on the Plane or?
No, I'm just kidding.
- No, fucking Money on the Plane.
- [Gary] I get it, I love it.
- But what's cool about it
the last video I shot there
was five levels on the plane.
There was a meditation room,
there was a party room,
there was a room that had
sharks swimming in it,
there was a massage room
there was a cannabis room
so like taking these visuals
and really stimulating
the audience to another level.
- Good for you, I love it.
- That's a real thing?
- Oh legit.
- Where's that at, I wanna
do that, where is that?
- [Gary] Where's the plane, you mean?
- Yeah, we'll uh,
you gotta buy a ticket (laughing).
- You hustling out here, I like it.
- [Lexy] Wow, I gotta buy one?
We're on the show together
and now I gotta buy...
- Oh, we're doing it like that.
Who wants some sneakers?
You guys want a book?
- Then you know what I'm
charging you for this.
- [Gary] Lex.
- Music
- [Gary] Music, music,
- I want to release my E.P.
I want to tour it either
opening up for someone or
just myself.
- Your song right now,
that really popped me.
- [Lexy] Peace Sign?
- Peace Sign really hit.
- It's a poppy.
- Like I was walking down
the street the other day
and just walking down
street and people loved it
yeah, and I heard I was super smiling.
- I love it.
- [Gary] That caught some wind right?
- It is, it needs more wind.
Shot out to radio stations out there.
It's a really catchy song.
Younger kids like it,
older people like it.
It's just like a ultimate
whoever you want to give
the peace sign to like,
- So whose, when do you
want the project to launch.
- I'm not positive, hopefully
within the next couple months.
- Whose the producer you
want to work with the most?
- Mmm, I wanna work with the most?
- [Gary] Anybody stand out?
- I mean,
- Or whose a producer
you want to work with,
any body stand out, or it's not like that?
- It's not really like that,
cause' I'm around a lot of
producers that I really like
they can reach out to me.
There's some DJs that you
know, I'd like to collab with
Fiesta is pretty dope.
- How does it work, do you hear something
and you're just like that?
- In the studio?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I like to listen to the beats.
I don't really like the process
of them creating the track.
I'll go in there and automatically.
Oh, I have a melody, boom let's do it.
And then I just write to it.
It's like that.
- How often do you write?
- Whenever I'm in the studio.
I don't ever right when
I'm not in the studio.
- Really?
- No, I don't like writing
like sitting on the couch like...
- I love people's process man.
- [Nigel] Yeah that's crazy.
- No, no, no I gotta be in there,
I have to hear a beat.
Sometimes I'm in my car and
I'll hear a song on the radio
and I try to like turn it down a little.
- [Gary] And it'll trigger something.
- It'll trigger something
and then I'll be in my notes
and I'll have two phones
And I'm trying to record while driving.
It's really bad.
But like I'll write some
full songs doing that.
- So funny, where my head just went.
In 2008, when I first
started my speaking career
there was a really big time speaker
and he looked at me and he was like,
Hey, you know I saw some video on line.
Like, you're really-
so he's like sitting, we're both speaking.
He's going up first.
I'm like an hour later.
We're in the green room.
He goes, how long did you
work on your presentation
for today's speech.
And, I was like, I don't
have a presentation
and it was super interesting.
(laughter)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And he was like,
and it was interesting,
it wasn't like I got
scared or thought he was,
it was an interesting conversation.
He was like, I've worked for three weeks
on this presentation
and he was talking about his process
and how he does the
slides and the key note
and this and that and changing the word
and like practice.
- [Lexy] I've never been like that.
- And I was like wow,
and then like I'm just like, to this day,
I'm just like go on stage and wing it.
- [Nigel] I love that, I love that.
- Because for me, my style is
I'm gonna talk about what I'm living.
This is the current state of
the internet, media, culture,
like this is what it is.
I would do it just as I'm doing this.
Whether it's one person or 80
thousand but it's just back
to people's process.
That's so interesting to me like
I love when I meet people.
I'm like, when do you write?
They're like when I feel it
or like this and that,
like only in the studio.
That's cool, which means
it's pretty improv.
- [Lexy] Mostly I get
inspired just in the studio.
Oh, it's mostly improv.
Or I'll have ideas of concepts.
- Like Peace Sign,
cause' I love that song.
How did that go down?
- Peace Sign, me and my friend
Jensen were in the studio
and then I think I was
talking about an ex-boyfriend
or someone I dated, which was yeah,
I don't, he actually came up
peace sign turn it around part.
And then we just wrote
the whole song around that
pretty much, it was amazing.
- Parting shots Nigel,
we're bouncing out of here.
- We're done already?
I was having so much fun.
- We're done, you get to say
anything you fucking want.
What do you want the world to know?
- Oh man, can you come back to me?
- I know damn that's a hard question.
- Shout out to Queens, you heard?
Shout out to Queens, GO
mode all day, that's it.
- I love it.
- I say, praise the lord and thank HaShem,
that's it.
- I love it man.
- Do you know who HaShem is?
- No
- HaShem is the name it means the name.
You know how the Game is the Game,
He is The Name, his name is so powerful.
- I love that, that's awesome.
- [Lexy] Oh.
- Right, that's the creator,
I just tap into a creative
source, that's it.
- I love that, thanks for being on, next?
- Well shit, go buy my
new sing Peace Sign.
- [Nigel] Right?
- Hallelujah to that.
- Thanks guys for being on.
- Thank you Gary you're the best.
- See you!
(upbeat music)